last thing I want to touch on with
Carrie Lake just the hilarity of the
final people insisting that she would
win even though it was clear she didn't
have the numbers Carrie Lake herself and
other extremists insisted she was going
to win until the very last moment at a
certain point you have to ask do they
not understand basic math do they not
understand the degree to which they need
to overwhelm the remaining ballots the
further they fall behind and don't they
realize wow
I haven't gotten 60 of the vote anywhere
so far I need 60 of everything that's
left to win it's probably over for me
they don't seem to get it or they don't
care let's go through this here is
Carrie Lake up until the last moment
look at how confidently she insisted I'm
gonna win I'm gonna win do you find it
somewhat problematic at all that your
opponent Katie Hobbs is a Terry estate
and she didn't recuse herself by the way
this happened in Georgia previously
where the secretary of state was running
for governor they they none of these
Republicans had any problem with it now
they have a problem with it I'm
overseeing this election an election
that she's actually very much running in
yes I did as a matter of fact right
after I got into the race I've done
threw my hat into the ring in June of
21. that next month in July I recognize
that would be a problem and we put out a
very hard push for her to recuse herself
from any aspects of her job as Secretary
of State that oversaw any part of the
elections and she refused to do so and
we saw how botched the August 2nd
Primary election was much of that can be
attributed to her incompetence and now
we're seeing all the problems with this
election and I think it's just going to
when I win it's going to be a sigh of
relief yeah well that was uh that was
yesterday and indeed the sigh of relief
was that Kerry Lake lost here's Marjorie
Taylor Greene talking about that
critical Arizona race just yesterday we
lost in 2020 because of that because of
the mail-in ballots and because it was
right for election fraud and now we're
watching it again especially in Carrie
likes race over in Arizona this this
shouldn't be this way everyone was
calling for a red wave either all the
pollsters were wrong and they need to be
fired and that's Republican Democrat I
mean that's what they've been saying
forever these Republicans forever have
been saying fire the pollsters media
pollster saying that we were going to
get a red wave or we have to finally
acknowledge the fact or at least we have
to get the other side to acknowledge the
fact and admit the truth that mail-in
ballots is the biggest problem in our
elections mail-in ballots are the
biggest problem in our election so
Marjorie Taylor green jumping Full Speed
Ahead into the fraud element and she
says listen all these right-wing
pollsters told us there was going to be
a red wave now there wasn't it must have
been fraud it must have been fraud and
then here is January 6th Riot organizer
Ali Alexander saying that he's going to
will Kerry Lake to win this was just
yesterday morning hours later she lost
even
even gonna lose
yes and I know that sounds crazy yes
but
just don't catch me on a wild day
Pete Davidson one time got on my bad
side
yeah and almost killed himself
so what
you're not gonna believe me it doesn't
matter
the point is is that no one needs to
believe you the first time the point is
you just need to tell them the first
time okay do you understand this no this
is gonna sound kooky for y'all and cozy
but you guys don't understand the
esoteric oh
what if I told you
that all of us are capable of traveling
well not all of us because you're not
smart enough but what if I told you that
there are a lot of people capable of
time traveling they just don't know it
what if I told you that time traveling
is
easier than you think yep well uh this
is exactly the caliber of person that
was supporting Kerry lake so you know
whether it's because it was willed or
prayed for or someone traveled forward
in time or back in time Kerry lake has
lost and we can all rejoice it is a
bullet dodged
huge work to be done over the next two
years make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel a lot of people 3.2
million last month watched our videos
didn't subscribe to the YouTube channel
make sure you hit that subscribe button
help us get to 2 million and we will
take a very quick break and be back
after this before you go if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more please
make sure to subscribe to my YouTube
channel you can click the Subscribe
button below or above or wherever it is
on your screen and if you want to
support my work even more strongly the
best way is to get a membership at
joinpakman.com And subscribe to the
podcast for the David packman show there
you can check out interviews longer
clips and much more it's on all the big
podcasting platforms just search for the
David packman show and all the links are
also Down Below in the video description